[Music]
patrick is with us patrick's in columbus
ohio hi patrick how are you
hey dave thank you for having me
sure what's up
hey so
i paid off my student loans back in 2020
um and then
from about from about march 13th to when
i finally paid them off uh there's about
six grand in there and i'm reading that
i could potentially ask a refund
on that paint on those payments and my
thought hood is with this news coming
out whether it happens
i won't do it if it sounds shady but uh
is it a possibility that i could get
some money since i paid off my student
loans but uh get the government to pay a
portion of it for me so here's the thing
the biden administration has given
almost zero details
on how this is going to be implemented
or the nuances things like you're
talking about
and everybody and his brother has
written an opinion piece including me
um now on this whole thing and uh and so
you know what we're doing is we're
guessing how it's all going to roll out
so that has not been announced by the
white house
that was announced by someone in an
opinion piece that they think it might
happen that way
and the details are not out on this so
um i you know but i don't know anything
because i never thought we'd actually
get to the place that we forgave student
loans
so i'm stupid i just my ability to i was
able to predict that he was going to do
something by the end of the year into
the by the end of the august by
correctly but i was not able to predict
that he actually is going to do
something of substance which maybe he
hasn't yet we'll see but so i don't know
if this is real i think that you know
we there's no indication from an
official that this is real but what
you're proposing i have seen what you're
talking about though um so let's see
what would i do if i were in your shoes
would i go back and get the money for
free
um
here's here
let me answer it this way i try to
answer questions what would i do you
know and that's to be fair in other
words not to be hypocritical so
here's the thing
i have been against the lottery in the
state of tennessee since it started many
many many years ago
because it is a tax on poor people
the vast majority of the people the zip
codes that raise eighty percent of the
lottery money are poor zip codes
the vast majority of the money going in
the lottery but more than 80 of it is
from poor people
and so lower income zip codes now
what's the lottery used for in the state
of tennessee it's used to give each kid
three to four thousand dollars towards
their tuition to go to college so it's
poor people sending middle class and
upper class people's kids to college
um and so i'm morally against that and i
i campaigned against it when the state
passed it i obviously my side lost we've
had it for a long time but when my kids
went to college there was free lottery
money available for my kids to go to
college i could have as a
multi-multi-multi-millionaire
accepted at the time it was three
thousand i think it's more than that now
three or four thousand dollars per kid
per year
towards their tuition it was available
to me it was legal
it was the program
but i had campaigned against it on the
auspices that it was morally wrong
because i don't believe more poor people
sending rich people's kids to college is
right
and taking advantage of and tac it's a
tax on the poor it's what the lottery is
and so i don't believe it's right so i
just i don't do it
now so so what i when my kids got ready
college i did not take that money
because to me
that would be a lack of integrity after
i had campaigned against it so
if i if i were in the situation today as
hard at hardcore as i've been against
student loan forgiveness for me my
family to actually accept
student loan forgiveness would be super
hypocritical agreed
agreed so if so i'll leave that on you
and it's not saying you're right or
wrong either way but if you have had
like strong conversations with your
friends over coffee and you say this is
wrong this is wrong this is wrong i
don't think it's morally right then you
should not accept it if you're
ambivalent you're kind of in the middle
i think you're okay morally to accept it
what do you think there's nothing
unethical here if i'm in issues i'm
going hey i could have some money yeah
the only thing being unethical is if you
took a stand against it and then took it
sure but to say hey i'm going to get
this refund i'm going to apply it to my
baby steps it's going to help me in a
financial journey and this is a legal
there's no loopholes here i think he
should go ahead and do it and this is
coming from studentaid.gov education
department this is where this news is
coming from so it's it's a legitimate
source but nothing's actually happened
yet so it's still a little bit of
we don't really know what could happen
here's the thing they did not write this
i mean they did not write this proposal
from biden
biden sent senate to them they're saying
and they have not related they have not
had time yet they're guessing what it
might look like too
and so no it's it's i it's not coming
out of the white house it's coming out
of the deep bowels of a bureaucracy and
we'll see if any of that actually makes
it to the light of day i you know if
you're ambivalent kind of in the middle
agnostic to the whole thing you don't
have a stand on it take the money
if you're all for student loan
forgiveness i would take the money you
should be able to do that without
conscience but if you've been raising a
banner like i have for many years that
this is wrong then um
or at least it's wrong while you're
still making the loans you know and then
after that we can discuss everything
just infuriating but then you have to do
this so i didn't take the lottery money
i didn't take the ppp money
our company could have gotten a big
check during ppp and i'm telling people
this is a bad idea stay away from this
it's going to turn into a loan you're
stepping up on a trapdoor these guys are
going to choke you later you need to
stay out of it and it that ppp thing
very quietly has ruined some lives
and i'm so glad we didn't take it but
for me to stay out be on the radio going
it's horrible and then y'all send me my
check you know i'll take one yeah so
basically if it's not against your
values go for it nothing unethical about
it yeah so that's the thing so for
here's another example the titans
stadium came into nashville many years
ago and like almost every stadium or
sports complex that comes in they ask
the city for
free taxes
no taxes for years or forever they ask
the city to put to borrow money and put
into the project some cases ask the city
to build the project or half of it or
whatever and uh that's government money
citizens money going into a private
enterprise and it's not like nfl owners
need money hello okay but but i actually
was okay with them doing that which
sounds weird to a guy like me but and
the reason is is because of what that
creates in the overall economy
it's not necessarily the titans
themselves or the sports team itself
that's the big deal it's all the things
that it does for the economy
all the other jobs and all the other
things that happen in the economy
that is around it it make it's a good
deal for the city the city makes more
and increased tax revenue off of the
other things then it then they gave up
in the revenue on the deal so i said do
it okay and so when we did this piece of
ground
and we built this building we were given
some tax breaks because we're a huge
employer in the state of tennessee i
accepted those
and so uh you know that is not
incongruent that is not incongruent um
so because i say dave that's not fair
you take tax credits what's the
difference here yeah what do you say to
those well the difference is number one
uh i didn't borrow something and then
ask for it to be forgiven after i
promised to repay it
there's no there's no value issue on the
line number one but number two what i'm
saying is i've been consistent on what
i've done in private
and the stands of taking public
and that's all we would ask any of you
to do
is is you know whatever you whatever you
believe just be that all the time and
quit being freaking well you you know i
don't know what the gen z version of
two-faced is but we used to call it
two-faced quit being two-faced you're
different on sunday than you are on
monday
stop it
you know won't you just be like the same
all the time
and so consequently you know my
christian friends are as angry at me for
being not christian enough as my
non-christian friends are because i'm a
christian and good god you just can't
win you've never been in the business of
making everyone happy dave we know that
really that's one thing i do know about
you and we love it well well we you know
welcome to the parade
[Laughter]
uh horse skate right welcome to the
parade this is the ramsey show